العربيه تواكب وصول رعايه الهند الذين
قدموا قبل قليل على سفينه عسكريه هنديه
وتوقفت او وقفت على رصيف ميناء جده
الاسلامي هذا هذه المنطقه التي نتواجد
فيها هي المنطقه الثانيه في لحظات انهاء
اجراءات القادمين من الجنسيات المختلفه
سواء لهذه السفينه السفينه الهنديه ام
كذلك الجنسيات المختلفه من رعايه من
جنسيات مختلفه الذين قدموا من السودان
طبعا هذه المرحله هي المرحله المهمه
تحديدا لماذا لان معظم من يشاهدهم على
ويقفون في صف واحد او في طوابير متعدده
لانهاء اجراءات عبر منصات الجوازات
التابعه لوزاره الداخليه السعوديه ليس
لديهم تاشيرات دخول الى السعوديه فيمنح
لهم تاشيره دخول طارئه سريعه حتى تمكنهم
من الدخول الى السعوديه وبعد ذلك يتم
مغادرتهم بعد التنسيق مع سفاراتهم
وقنصلياتهم للمغادره من جده الى بلدانهم
طبعا هذه المنصه كل شخص يقف فيها يتم
انهاء اجراءات اجراءاته في 30 ثانيه حيث
يتم اخذ معلوماتهم او يؤخذ جوازه ومنحه
التاشيره وبعد ذلك عمليه تطابق المعلومات
مع الشخص الموجود وبعدها يتم وضع او تنفيذ
عمليه البصمه والعلامات الحيويه الخاصه به
حتى يتم منحه هذه التاشيره وكما نشاهد هذه
الفتره التي يقضيها الشخص الواحد لا
تتجاوز الثلاثين ثانيه وبعد ذلك يتم اخذ
صوره له من الكاميرا المعده والخاصه
بمنصات الجوازات السعوديه طبعا لدينا هنا
سيده من من الجوازات السعوديه ولدينا ايضا
هنا اخر ومنصه اخرى هنا لدينا العديد من
المنصات التي يتم فيها انهاء اجراءات كل
هؤلاء الرعايا حتى يتم تسهيل مهمه انهاء
اجراءات بشكل سريع وكذلك تسهيل مهمتهم في
هذه الصاله الكبرى نتحدث هنا يتجاوز المئه
وستين منصه انهاء اجراءات يتم فتحها في
حاله ازداد العدد طبعا يوم اليومين
الماضيين استقبلت هذه الصلاه تحديدا اكثر
من 1800 شخص وتم انهاء اجراءاتهم في وقت
وجيز وسريع وبعد ذلك يتم اخذ هؤلاء
الاشخاص والجنسيات التي قدمت الى صاله
القدوم في ميناء جده الاسلامي والتوجه بهم
الى حافلات الى مقر اقامتهم الفندقيه
والتي تم اعدادها والتنسيق معها مع
الخارجيه السعوديه التي ايضا هناك خدمات
لوجستي تقوم بها مع مشاركه مع الجهات
الاخرى وكذلك السفرات والقنصليات وهذه
الثلاثين الثانيه الذي كنا نرصد الحاله
فيها قد انتهى وغادر
وامان وهذا الشخص الاخر الان لو ايضا يتم
انهاء في اجراءاته بنفس الطريقه وبنفس
الحاله اذا لم يكن او منحه بدايه التاشيره
او التاشيره طارئه حتى يمكنه من الدخول
والعبور من هذه البوابه الى الحافله
باتجاه الاراضي السعوديه او كذلك الحافله
التي سوف تقله الى مقر اقامته طيب هاني
يسمح لي فقط بالتنوين هذا الخبر عاجل نقل
عن الخارجيه السعوديه التي تقول اجمالي من
تم اجلؤه من السودان الفاني وسبعمائه شخصا
من 78 جنسيه طيب اعاني بحسب ايضا متابعتك
مع هؤلاء الرعايه الذين تم اجلائهم هل من
قصص او التجارب رووها لك يشوهها او حول ما
يعيشوه في الخرطوم او في السودان او
المناطق التي جاءوا منها عطفا على ما يحدث
من تطورات هناك واشتباكات عسكريه بين
الجيش والدعم السريع ما الذي يعيشوه هناك
تحديدا
قبل ان نتحدث عن هذه القصص والحكايات التي
كنا نتحدث فيها مع الجنسيات المختلفه التي
وصلت الى السعوديه نتحدث عن الان معضله
وايضا من الصعوبات والتحديات التي قد
تواجه بعض البلدان وقد تواجه في عمليه نقل
رعاياها نتحدث ان اعداد هناك في تحديدا في
بورسودان اعداد كبيره نتحدث كنا نتحدث مع
احد الجنسيات العربيه وابلغنا ان اذا غادر
بشكل يومي الف شخص فان فانه ياتي بعدهم
الف شخص اخرين هؤلاء فقط من وصلوا الى
نادي الموانئ في بورت سودان المنطقه التي
يتم تجمع بها وتم ايضا هذه المنطقه تحديدا
بورت سودان المنطقه التي تم تجمع بها هي
بناء على مواصلات الجميع عبر مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي الذي اصبح هذا المكان
هو مكان التجمع هناك من ياتي من الخرطوم
ويقطع مسافه الخمسه عشر ساعه وبعضهم ايضا
من ياتي من غرب السودان لياتي الى هذه
المنطقه من اجل النجاه والبحث عن سفينه او
طائره تتم نقله لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات